[Music]
hey guys it's Alicia Malone welcome to
another episode of bandango indie movie
guide and today I'm talking about three
films featuring three very interesting
women and I'm focusing on the theme of
women this week because tada this is the
very first copy of my very first book is
called backwards and in heels it's going
to be out August 15 you can pre-order on
Amazon now it's about the past present
future for women working in Hollywood
and also this week at San Diego
comic-con I'm going to be moderating a
very special panel in collaboration with
Fandango called the female voices of
film Twitter starring an excellent
lineup of very inspirational strong
women who I love to follow on social
media make sure you don't miss it it's
at 1:30 p.m. and the Courtin grand
theater up against a little panel called
a game of Thrones but if you don't go to
that make sure you come and check out my
panel with Fandango and I'll give
everyone a hug to come free hugs but
onto this week's films let's start with
one you can see in theaters called
landline it's directed by Gillian Rogues
pieres who did obvious child and once
again she retains with Jenny slate what
did you do to that crack has anyone
spoken to Dana the sweet holic a date
not yet I was hoping the dress wouldn't
get her excited
what is that when David rearranged he
finally did it
yes nice very good it's good I'm reading
Hammacher Schlemmer they're advertising
the world's fastest razor blade very
totally good this is the story of two
sisters living in the 90s in 1995
Manhattan they start to realize that
their father is having an affair and
they want to follow him to try and find
out who he's having an affair with and
whether their mother knows anything
about it why wasn't an affair oh my god
why does he sometimes refer to himself
as her Pillsbury doughboys
oh because he calls his junk dough oh
yeah gosh just broke my brain obvious
child was a unique indeed take on the
rom-com and landline is the unique indie
take on coming-of-age it's about trying
to figure out who you really are not
just who you present to the world and
that can happen at any age whether
you're a teenager or an adult I'm
clearly trying to figure out if the life
that I picked for myself is even the one
that I want you may never figure that
out it's sweet funny
honest and quirky and features a great
performance by Jenny slate landline it's
very relatable it's got great female
characters who are complex and layered
made by a wonderful female director
so check out landline in limited
theaters this weekend it is a great time
love you guys to watch you when you're
making crazy you are really a weird
little bird you know that I'm trying to
be happy
course drinks I've ever had trilliant
whiskey Mountain Dew right now to a very
different film which also features an
interesting female character in fact
she's the strongest bravest and smartest
of them all it's called killing ground
and it is an australian horror beautiful
pretty much our remember to the tenth
this plenty of room we can set up over
here
this movie will make you not want to go
camping ever again
it's about a young couple who go to a
secluded place in australia to celebrate
New Year's Eve when they get there they
discover that there's another tent
that's already been set up but they
can't find the family it belongs to the
film cuts back and forth between the
couple and the family and even though
it's all set within the same place you
soon realize that these two stories are
taking place on different timelines Oh
trouble do I scare you are you a ranger
[Music]
or that may seem like very familiar
horror territory but first time directed
Damien power takes those tropes and
gives them a twist and it will keep you
on the edge of your seat the whole final
act is extremely tense I had to look
away but I didn't want to look away who
it is creepy as all get-out but once
again proves that Australian horror is
having a huge resurgence
I recommend this film killing ground out
in limited theaters from this weekend
you can make the last few opportunities
and my third film that features a very
interesting female character is the
Fifth Element
okay this is not technically an MV but I
wanted to celebrate this movie because
can you believe it's been 20 years since
the Fifth Element came out directed by
Luc Besson who is known for his
fascinating strong complex female
protagonists and here you have Leeloo
played by Mila Jovovich The Fifth
Element
someone who could actually save the
planet and she needs help from a
military leader turned cab driver played
by Bruce Willis
[Music]
she goes off
I was really lucky to get to go to the
Hollywood Forever Cemetery here in LA
which doesn't sound like a great place
to watch a movie but trust me it is
amongst the graves but in a clear spot
luc besson was there to introduce the
film I want to thank the hundreds of
leaders I've seen and it's just amazing
push back you're making development of
course classic thank you baby thank you
watching it on the big screen is of
course such a treat but you can now
watch it at home in 4k Ultra HD both
visuals are going to pop off the screen
and that's in celebration of its 20th
anniversary
so if you can I highly recommend you
find landline the quirky coming-of-age
story or the creepy Australian horror
chilling gram or you can stay at home
and watch The Fifth Element
I'm Alicia Malone as always let me know
which films you've been watching in the
comments below or by following me on
Twitter at Alicia Malone
[Music]